[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to my tomes
of terror book review series
so
here is a novel uh canada 2017
and it's called the house on rectory
lane by a british author named stuart
james now i came across this book kind
of randomly uh as i do a lot of the
books that i do for this uh series while
i was kind of like browsing through the
suggestions that they gave me on my
kindle unlimited
now it had kind of like an intriguing
sounding title it had a whole bunch of
four and five star reviews and it was
free to read uh so i just decided to
give it a shot why not
i thought initially that i had never
read anything by this author before
uh i deliberately did not read the
synopsis prior to diving into the book
which is what i usually do um you know
if you know me at all i've mentioned
that before i like to come into things
kind of fresh so
i tend to pick books
not necessarily just by the titles or
the covers but it's just like the whole
vibe of like what does this look like it
would probably be about to me um and
usually i'll go on whether it's really
highly rated or not if there's like a
lot of ratings and a lot of them are
really high then i'm probably like yeah
this book is probably like pretty good
now after i read the book and i was
doing a little bit of research about it
like for this video i discovered a
couple of things uh one of those being
the fact that this book actually won the
international book award in horror
fiction at the american book fest like
back when it came out 2016 2017 2018
whenever it was and it had a [ __ ] ton of
praise like positive reviews one of the
um blurbs i saw as i was called the
scariest thriller in years similar kind
of sentiments to that
but another thing i realized while i was
doing this research was that a few
months ago
i had checked out another book by the
same author stuart james uh and it was
also on the kindle unlimited like read
it for free plan and this one was like i
guess his newest novel 2022 and it's
called creeper
and i started reading it and i just
really couldn't get into it i couldn't
really like put my finger on what it was
but after like 30 40 pages i was just
like i just can't like vibe with this
and i dnf'd it so
even though i thought that i had never
read anything by this author before uh i
actually had started to read one of his
newer books and couldn't really get
through it it's not that it was bad per
se it was just there was something about
it that like wasn't vibing with me so i
just like stopped reading probably goes
to show i should probably pay more
attention to like the author's names i
guess then maybe just like the title of
it when i'm just like randomly scrolling
through but whatever now okay so i will
say that although i didn't dislike the
house on rectory lane overall
um and i did you know i will note find
it interesting enough to finish in one
sitting i actually read it in a single
afternoon
but there was a quality about it that
really kind of like rubbed me the wrong
way
and after i realized that this was the
same writer as creeper something kind of
like clicked in my head after that and i
figured out oh this is exactly the same
writing style that had caused me to
abandon the book creeper before because
i just couldn't get into it
so i will say that my ambivalence toward
the house on rectory lane while i was
reading it was less a result of like not
enjoying the story which um again is
like pretty compelling uh it goes a
little far-fetched toward the end but
that wasn't like a deal breaker or
anything but i think for me it was more
like a dislike of the execution like the
writing style i'll try to articulate
what i'm talking about like more toward
the end of the video if i can sort of
like
define it anyway because it's kind of
like hard for me to put into words so
the novel starts out with this kind of
brief prologue and it's basically just
describing a woman who's running like
obviously very terrified through a house
being pursued by a camera wielding
attacker
and then after that we get to our main
characters and like the main meat of the
story so the house on rectory lane
follows a family which consists of a dad
named jake a mom named kate and their
five-year-old son sean
now they live in the camden district of
london
and though the couple actually kind of
they're both from that area and they
really do love like a lot of aspects of
big city life um they like that there
are so many pubs and so many social
activities and music shows and stuff
like that like right within walking
distance they really like that all their
friends live nearby and they're able to
go out and see their friends like quite
often
but on the other hand now that they have
like a small kid and they're sort of
getting a little bit older they're kind
of getting tired of this sort of like
constant congestion the traffic parking
issues just the general like noise and
overcrowding that kind of comes with
living in a metropolis of that side size
so they decide that uh you know much
like the protagonist in many a horror
novel
over the years uh they decide they want
a quieter life out in the country
because they think that's gonna be
better
haven't they seen any horror movies
obviously not um but yeah so they want
to live out in the country where they
have some more privacy where their
little boy can like run around in the
yard and then no one will bother them
and stuff like that now one thing that
now they had kind of been planning this
before but one of the things that sort
of sends their moving plans into
overdrive
is
an incident that happens like pretty
near the beginning of the book where
jake is actually threatened by this
crazy guy uh with a knife during his
morning commute i believe it is now the
thing he owns like a plumbing company
like he's a plumbing contractor so
that's one thing that's like helping him
out with a move i'm presuming that he's
like
not well off well off but he's like you
know he's financially okay he owns his
own business and he's going to like
expand he's leaving the one in london
like in the hands of his second in
command and then he's gonna open up like
another franchise or another one like
out in the country that's how he's uh
gonna do it
so after this knife uh attacker incident
uh there they've become more convinced
than ever that moving out of london is
absolutely a fantastic idea the best
thing for them to do
so jake and kate end up purchasing what
seems like a perfect somewhat secluded
home out in the sticks now the house
itself is called the rectory and it's
situated on you guessed it rectory lane
now there are a couple of other houses
on the same like in the same street or
whatever and there's a like a small
quite bustling village nearby but all in
all the house itself the rectory is very
private it has you know it's kind of
like has woods or fields around it it
has its own automatic gate that you have
to open with a little clicker thing it
has all this so you can't really like
come up to it without somebody knowing
about it that kind of stuff so far so
good
uh but then of course
weird [ __ ] starts happening that
obviously makes the family think they've
made a terrible mistake in moving out
here in the middle of nowhere
for example uh a few random people in
the village shortly after they move in
like when they're at the hardware store
or whatever the hell either come out and
outright warn jake to get the [ __ ] out
of the house as soon as possible because
it's bad news
or they'll just kind of go more subtle
with it like good luck buddy you know
that kind of stuff but they're not
really they won't really like tell them
what the deal is uh the estate agent who
sold them the house who's kind of this
slick and a little bit comes across like
a little bit sleazy like he has like a
lot of money obviously because he's kind
of flashy like he's got like a flashy
car um his name's anton and he actually
told him he's like well this is probably
nothing to be alarmed about but uh the
last family that lived in this house the
prescotts they just uh up and
disappeared one day that nobody has
heard from them since that's quite
mysterious yeah so that's a little
disquieting more ominous than that the
nearest house to them which is called
rose cottage now when they first move in
it initially appears occupied it has
like this really really nice like
beautifully manicured lawn there's like
a little friendly dog outside but then
sometimes when they're kind of like
looking in the windows it looks like
nobody's in there like there's no
furniture and [ __ ] like that so jake
starts to get curious about this
and as he's out on a run one day he sees
through the window what appears to be a
man punching a woman in the face and her
like subsequently like falling on the
ground
later on he also sees what appears to be
the same guy looking for all the world
as though he's burying a body in the
backyard
now when jake calls the cops and has
them out there to look around they don't
find anything out there there are also
these other neighbors that they have who
live in one of the other houses on
rectory lane whose names are pete and
laura and they're like super friendly
and super welcoming and jake and kate
are all happy because they're like oh
hey we're making friends already and
it's like we can hang out because you
know they do kind of feel isolated from
their friends like you know they left
all their friends back in the city
but pete and laura also despite their
friendliness uh have a tendency to kind
of like show up unannounced hey we
brought beers you know what i mean and
then like they just kind of want to hang
out like all night even when you know
jake and kate were like hey we were kind
of hoping to like have a romantic
evening in front of the fireplace or
something like that but then these two
clods show up and you know so they're
kind of like well you guys are nice but
you know a little bit of a party foul
there so there's that on top of all that
the power keeps going out every now and
then like it'll go off and it'll come
back on it'll go off and it'll come back
on and it's starting to get like really
annoying
um and so they call the power company
and they're like look well it doesn't
look like there's anything at this end
maybe somebody is like [ __ ] around
with your power box like outside and it
does indeed like look like maybe
somebody is doing that now after kate
one time sees a dude lurking around out
in the garden or whatever
jake calls a local guy named adam i
think to get an alarm system installed
but the guy just like shows up to do the
work before jake really kind of he'd
been talk to him about yeah we'll do
this and that and the other but he
hadn't like made a solid appointment
like yeah let's turn up does he just
kind of like turn up turned up and he's
like oh hey i'm here to like do your
alarm system they're like okay yeah it's
so it's kind of like really odd [ __ ]
like that there's also the uh not
insubstantial matter of uh several young
women disappearing from in and around
the village
uh jake frequently feeling as though
there's like this car like a black jeep
like following him around like wherever
he goes
and as if all this wasn't enough jake
also comes across like not too long
after they've moved in when he's putting
some stuff up in storage he's up in the
attic and he finds this old
dvd
and it has home movies of a family on it
who they presume are the prescotts and
later find out that that is uh indeed
who they are
and although the footage is like normal
at first like hey here's a birthday
party here's the kids playing in the
garden or whatever um a scene at the
very end shows what appears to be like a
terror-stricken woman running through
the rectory the house being chased by
someone holding the camera which is kind
of like the thing that we saw in the
prologue so all of these bizarre events
really do
get you involved and invested in this
mystery that's going on and i was
actually like pretty absorbed enough in
the plot to
want to figure out what the hell is
going on here like what did all these
things have to do with one another now
because this is a thriller and is
advertised as such it is like it's comes
up on horror stuff too but it's thriller
in the sense that i just assumed that
well this is going to be like a
non-supernatural uh explanation for the
shenanigans which usually is the
distinction i think between a thriller
and horror but this does have horror
elements to it but i will say too that i
really liked the idea of all of these
incidents while seemingly unrelated i
was like oh maybe they're all connected
somehow
what is it that connects them is this
like some big conspiracy or something
like that so i was actually kind of like
invested in the mystery at that level
but
as i mentioned earlier uh i think the
thing about this novel that kind of kept
me from enjoying it as much as i
probably would have
was mostly the writing style and to a
lesser extent the formatting issues like
the kindle e4 and i've the kindle ebook
format and i've seen this on other ones
i don't think it's necessarily the
author's fault because i'm not sure like
who lays these out like i lay out my own
kindle books as well and there is like a
program for doing that but it's very
very frustrating to use at least for me
and a lot of times i can't get a real
consistent look even though this
app is supposedly made for you know kind
of formatting it in the correct way so
it'll look as good as possible on most
people's devices um so i'm not really
gonna like blame people for that kind of
formatting because i've dealt with my
own issues with that and it's really
really hard to get right but there were
some other formatting issues that
probably were like the authors or the
editors look out
um there weren't really that many
spelling errors because you guys know
how what a stickler am about like
spelling errors and stuff i didn't
really notice too many of those but
there were a bunch of grammatical errors
um usually run-on sentences and you guys
know because i think i've brought up on
book before like how everything was run
on sentences and it drove me crazy uh so
there's that
there was also kind of a very
distracting tendency for the author
sometimes he would put
a couple of different like different
characters dialogue
in the same paragraph which generally i
mean i don't know what the rule i'm i
was generally taught that that's
not what you're supposed to do like when
a new person is speaking you're supposed
to go to like a new paragraph because
when you put the same when you put
different people talking in one
paragraph i'm just like well who the
[ __ ] is this talking now it's like very
very confusing so yeah a few times i was
just kind of like oh this is two
different people talking they should
have put this in another paragraph so
that kind of was like very distracting
on a related note this is just something
else that i noticed
i have also never been a big fan of the
british custom because it's a british
author remember i said of using only
single quotes to enclose the dialogue
now this obviously isn't the writer's
fault because that's just how they do it
over there but i have to say that i've
always much preferred the american
method of enclosing dialogue in double
quotes because it makes it stand out
more from like the rest of the text you
know what i'm saying when it's just like
a single quote it looks too much like an
apostrophe you can't see it as well and
i'm just like wait is this talking or is
this exposition what the [ __ ] so i you
know but that's like i said that's not
his fault because they all do that in
britain over there and it drives me
crazy every single time
but you know that's just like different
standards uh but in this book speaking
of quotes there were many instances
where quote marks were left out
altogether like there'd be somebody
talking and then there'd be exposition
but there was no quote at the end so you
didn't know like if where the dialogue
ended so that's obviously like a typo i
have to say too i found the
characterization like a little bit i
guess like flat underwhelming type of
thing jake was kind of like the main
character so he was like the most
fleshed out
but i felt like his reactions and his
motivations and stuff like that were
kind of inconsistent like at the
beginning he seemed sort of like
not necessarily fearful but kind of like
that more like a non-confrontational
type of dude um kind of
not like i said i want to say like
nervous or anxiety written but like a
little bit along those lines but then
like um at the end he was almost kind of
acting like a big action badass and it
was kind of like came out of nowhere you
know i mean like he didn't really have
any
i don't know like any build up to that
it just seemed very strange to me
i will say too that he also brought a
lot of trouble on himself by one going
places he probably shouldn't have like
and that a normal person wouldn't go and
um but you know i guess that's par for
the course in horror but he's like doing
stupid [ __ ] all the time i mean he made
some like really unwise and decisions
and sometimes some kind of
mind-boggling ones i'm just like dude
what the hell are you even doing so that
was that um but at least he got it
better than his wife kate who
really didn't seem fleshed out to me at
all um the only impression i got of her
was that she was hot um because that's
what the author called her like through
jake's eyes seeing her i was like okay
well she's hot what else like she's a
hot woman with long black hair that's
pretty much the only
the only thing that i got so you know
there was that
now the story jumps back and forth from
the perspective of different characters
which is fine a lot of books do that
but in one case uh i felt as though this
was kind of a cheat because now i'm
trying not i'm gonna say this like
without spoiling some of the like
because there's some pretty big plot
twist toward the end so i'm gonna try
and say something vague enough that it's
not spoiling it
uh so i felt this was a cheat because
a bunch of scenes had been told from the
perspective of one particular character
who ended up not being who or what you
thought they were
uh and that means to me that the author
deliberately withheld information from
the reader for the sake of the twist
when if you were actually in that
character's head as you
purportedly were
you would have had more of an idea what
was going on so it was like a deliberate
deliberate withholding of information
even though you're supposedly seeing
things from this character's perspective
and so i i don't know that really kind
of bothered me there are also like um
two cop characters in this who were kind
of like the main people working on this
investigation they were mostly fine but
again they sort of like talked to each
other
very expositionally like they would tell
each other
very rudimentary things about whatever
investigation they were working on when
you'd think that they would know their
jobs well enough that they wouldn't have
to say those things to each other
especially because it was established in
the story that these two had been
partners for a long time as they had
worked in another city and then when one
of them retired like you know moved to
this smaller town the other one followed
them because they liked being their
partner so much so they these two knew
each other for a long time and the fact
that they were like telling themselves
hey we're gonna do like xyz like i'm
like well duh that's just what you would
do like i don't think i don't know why
you would have to say that but yeah so
is that
i kind of felt like so i kind of felt
like a lot of it was making the mistake
of like telling and not showing um you
know which is something they always tell
you not to do whether it's writing books
or movies or whatever you're basically
putting
unrealistic dialogue into the mouths of
the characters in order to convey
information to the reader so you're like
you know these
this is stuff that they wouldn't say to
each other in real life so it just comes
across as like very clunky and like not
very natural in fact all of the actions
of the police characters like the whole
way that the investigation progressed
the way that the authorities responded
to certain things it came across as not
very realistic to me and it kind of came
across as somebody that was just like
hey i'm gonna like you know talk like
some narrator like on an investigation
discovery show or something like that
like it sounded kind of like that to me
um if if you read it you maybe you know
what i'm talking about like i said it's
kind of like hard for me to like explain
like what it is that i'm like what it is
if you haven't read it it's hard for me
to explain like what what the tone is
that i'm trying to get across there was
also this really weird thing where there
would be some big reveal or some big
exciting event or chase or something
like that and it would be like really
really briefly described and wrapped up
like in a couple sentences or like in a
paragraph or something sometimes i would
have to go back and read it again to
make sure wait what do did i just catch
what happened or like did something
happen and i just like skimmed right
over it because it was like so fast yeah
so like really significant events like
especially toward the end seemed to get
like really short shrift which i thought
was very odd and again toward the end
there were some really important like
set pieces and chases and things like
that that
really would have added a lot of tension
and stakes to the story but they got
resolved like way too easily you know i
mean it's like oh i break into this
place and it's like oh the door is
unlocked how convenient oh there's not
even anybody around oh how convenient it
was just kind of like that kind of thing
and i was like that's okay that was a
very odd choice it was just like there
wasn't really that many like obstacles
or danger or if there was danger it
would be like handled like really easily
you know what i mean i didn't really get
the sense that there were like these big
stakes you know like oh my god we're
gonna die like somebody's gonna get
killed or something like that i didn't
really get that sense and again i think
i mentioned this earlier the big twist
toward the end of the story was kind of
far-fetched not impossible i'm not
saying that
but it wasn't really all that believable
either especially considering like some
of the stuff that i mentioned earlier
and again once it's revealed it's just
kind of like the aftermath of it was
just like really quickly and easily kind
of like resolved and wrapped up it's
like oh well that was that you know what
i mean and i was just kind of like
already then you know now there is
another kind of twit well it's not
really a twist twist but there was like
another little reveal like at the very
very end that i thought was was better
and was like a lot more impactful like
oh [ __ ] you know what i mean but
still
i just couldn't quite buy like the whole
scenario you know what i mean it's just
there were too many plot holes to me
inconsistencies and i was just kind of
like okay i see what you're trying to do
there but i don't really think it earned
it i guess so yeah so in general like
the writing style of the thing it's kind
of not gonna lie it kind of got on my
nerves uh the sentences were just kind
of terse a lot of the sentences were of
similar length and cadence so it seemed
very like i'm not not like staccato but
it was just kind of like
i don't know it sounded kind of like if
you were reading it aloud it just seemed
like it didn't have much variation like
in the lengths of the sentences or
anything and a lot of the sentences too
were like very
unadorned i guess it's not that you have
to necessarily like pepper your writing
with big flowery language or you know
big long paragraphs of description or
anything but i mean there is something
to be said for
painting a picture in your reader's mind
which is you know ideally what you're
trying to do
and i felt like this novel didn't really
do that like at least for me
um and again the dialogue didn't sound
super naturalistic and some of the
conversations and some of the actions
that the people were doing like
especially if they were like puttering
around the house or you know think like
just get in a car start in a car or
things like that that shouldn't seem
like a lot of filler i'm just kind of
like yeah let's get on with it that type
of thing so i mean on the whole i did
like the concept of this i did like the
story and it did keep me in enough
suspense
that i was like really curious to see
how it ended i mean like i said i did
read the whole thing like in one sitting
like in one afternoon because i was kind
of like i was into the story enough to
do that
but the writing style seemed kind of
grating you know what i mean i feel like
it probably maybe could have benefited
from an editor or a better editor if it
did have an editor i'm not entirely sure
i mean don't get me wrong this book does
have
[ __ ] tons of positive reviews on
goodreads and amazon way more positive
than negative ones in fact so obviously
i'm gonna say i was in the minority on
this like just finding it sort of okay
or just kind of mediocre um and that was
mostly just because of the style issues
that i've tried to kind of articulate so
i'm perfectly willing to concede that it
might just be me and my own
idiosyncrasies like other people might
have found the writing style perfectly
cromulate but i don't know there was
something about it that just like like i
said like kind of irritated me or like
god on my nerves
um so but if you're into thrillers you
might really dig it i mean a lot of
people did obviously there's it has a
lot of reviews and most of them are
positive but i found it kind of just
like middle of the road
and like i said the way it was written
just kind of irritated me which you know
i'm sorry to say that but that's kind of
it did just kind of get on my nerves you
know if you've read this or you've read
other books by the same author stuart
james let me know what you thought
because i'm actually kind of curious
about how different people might have
perceived it like if they
came at it because i did kind of feel
like there were some negative reviews
and they said some of the same things
that i was thinking like not exactly but
along the same line so i was like okay
well i'm glad i know it's not just me
but it's like i said it's a pretty small
minority of people that really didn't
like it but the people that didn't like
it didn't like it for the same reasons
that i didn't so i guess i'm not totally
crazy but i'd be curious about you
guys's opinions uh if you've read it
like i said if you have kindle unlimited
um it's on there for free a couple of
his books are not all of them but
like i said i started reading creeper
and i couldn't really get into it for
the same reason because of the writing
style so but i'm curious to see how
other people uh got into it or didn't so
let me know in the comments if you've
read it or if you have anything else
that you need to say about it and that
will do it for this tomes of terror i
will see you guys on the next one bye